here's uh so today we're gonna do
something fun and something different
something i'm really looking forward to
so
you know we've been on the david pakman
show i think about twice now
and um you know really appreciate his
dialogue in the way that he works and
the way he thinks and stuff like that
and so you know the last time we were on
on uh david pakman's show we sort of
talked a little bit about
you know sometimes he'll he'll say that
people will kind of disagree with him
and will be pretty vocal
and i i sort of mentioned to him that
you know it would be really cool to like
sort of talk to someone in an open-ended
non-judgmental manner about you know
what they believe and how they came to
believe it right because i find that so
much of political discourse right now is
like really just you know plastering the
other side is backward or idiots or
whatever
and one of the things that i really
appreciate about you know training to be
kind of non-judgmental through you know
be training to become a monk and sort of
accepting people where they're at and
like learning how to listen is all and
also like learning how to be a good
listener through
um you know training as a therapist
i think that those skills can actually
be applied to like you know
non-therapeutic or non-spiritual places
and one of the goals that we we kind of
are focused on you know here at healthy
gamer is just to try to understand
people right and educate people about
different different perspectives yep and
so a lot of times our focus has been on
like mental health but sometimes we'll
talk about stuff like you know how to
efficiently study and things like that
but today we're gonna try something a
little bit different and we're gonna uh
hop into a call with um david pakman as
well as uh a long time
i don't know if i should call him fan of
the show right but um i don't either one
who's who disagrees a lot with david
pakman but i understand calls in a lot
and i think they've got like a good and
healthy dialogue hopefully
and that's jimmy from philly and so
we're going to hop in with them and
we're just going to talk to jimmy for uh
and david for a little while and try to
sort of understand you know a little bit
about jimmy's experience of the world
and what he believes yeah so i know it's
a little bit different but i'm really
looking forward to it
um and let's get started okay so let's
see here i am ready i'm just gonna put
the camera on me until we've got
everything
up and running okay
so let me try to
video call all right so join a video
call
yo
we're going to unmute this okay
okay
figure out
what's the right um i just turned on the
camera
all right okay
i do what i did turn on camera
there we go
there you go you had it
beautiful and i'm just going to take a
second guys while we while we just chat
here since i don't usually use discord
just to get it all um
finely tuned so my audience can see
everybody
sure
okay
jimmy your camera was on briefly and
then turned off we cannot see you jimmy
oh
all right
there we go
you see me yes
okay
beautiful okay okay
okay
welcome everyone uh david do you want to
go ahead and kick things off or let me
do that yeah just to kind of set the the
situation here um so basically
i talked to all sorts of people on my
show at some point jimmy started calling
in and we know jimmy is jimmy from
philly
and we would he would bring to me
different ideas and questions and i
found jimmy to be an interesting
character a sad character in many ways a
concerning character in some ways as
well
um i think our report is sort of okay
although jimmy
does regularly say you know homophobic
things transphobic things racist things
etc and i think there's probably a lot
to dig into there about the the sort of
origins or oranges of that um a couple
things i'll mention about you know our
dialogue with with jimmy um jimmy has
talked to me about his um problems with
alcohol and you guys can probably see
he's got some bottles there over his
right shoulder and that's something i've
talked to jimmy about before
jimmy has talked about how he
has a daughter but at least at one point
wasn't allowed to see her because of
some physical violence that jimmy was at
least
i'll say he was accused of and we'll
maybe leave it to jimmy to tell us more
about the specifics of that
um jimmy was also arrested not long ago
because of as i understand it
chasing a car with four black teenagers
down the street while intoxicated and
that led to a sort of legal
situation as well for jimmy and that's
kind of the jimmy that i
that i know big picture and every once
in a while jimmy will say something
that's sort of open and he seems open to
considering other ideas etc but very
quickly he'll go back into
the transphobia the homophobia the
racism
um and uh and that that's kind of that's
jimmy as far as my relationship with him
which has been through the internet and
through my show
quite the introduction so i want to just
clarify a couple things so i noticed um
you know david
mentioned like alcohol use and things
like that so just to clarify and make
sure we're all on the same page jimmy i
am a psychiatrist
but i and my understanding of this
conversation is that you know i'm not
here because david's here too we're
going to just three people having a
conversation
i wanted to just make sure that are you
under the impression that i'm your
medical doctor or that i'm here to
diagnose you with anything
treat you for anything okay so we're
just gonna have a conversation and and
try to understand each other better so
the goal of what we do um the reason i
stream is just so that we can try to
understand people better and share that
understanding with everyone who's
watching um are you kind of cool with
that
yes
um just so you understand you know if
after the call if you do sort of decide
that you do want mental health support
or treatment or things like that you're
welcome to kind of message us and we can
kind of provide you with resources we do
that for every uh you know guests that
that comes on um
it you know but that's kind of it your
request we're not going to push anything
on you or recommend anything or anything
like that it's just sometimes
fine
okay
um so jimmy is it okay if i uh kind of
ask you i mean do you want to share a
little bit like do you want to offer an
introduction or or
i've got a couple of yeah
i mean
yeah so first of all like how did it
feel to hear david's kind of like litany
of how he introduced you well he's
gotten a lot of it wrong actually
okay
when i did the call with him last year
um
i clearly said that they were for
black 20-somethings not teenagers
um
this didn't occur in philadelphia it
occurred in the suburb of philadelphia
um let's see what else
um
i was arrested for public drunkenness
but i beat the cape
space they had a video of me going after
a car it doesn't prove that i was drunk
okay the rest of me because i was off my
pr the video showed them that i was off
the property and they said i was
publicly drunk the video showed that i
was angry
not that i was drunk
i was drunk okay
i i was very i i wasn't that drunk i was
they were ready to let me go at the
police station i said the m were in the
back of the police car so they wouldn't
let me go
sure
so what i'm kind of hearing is that like
you didn't get a fair rap from david
well
doc here's what happened okay so i'm a
trump supporter i have signs on my lawn
they continued to get stolen right
so i sat out there and was guarding them
and i'm drinking a little bit while i'm
out there four black men bomb rushed the
lawn
they take signs real quick
and they ride around the
toiling me three times [ __ ] whitey [ __ ]
trump
the second time they did it i ran in the
house i got a knife
third time they got caught at the light
i ran after the car i was a little tipsy
i stopped to stab the top of the tire i
should have stabbed the sidewall but the
knife just disintegrated in my hand
and uh they got out of the car laughing
and chased me back to the house and
something that we took a video of me
doing this
and uh
they gave it to the cops
and the cops locked me up for public
documents but i beat the case because
they never showed up they never they
didn't have a case
so
yeah so i mean thanks for sharing that
jimmy i appreciate it but what i'm kind
of curious about is like when you have
kind of your side of the story and like
i was frankly kind of shocked i mean
david is it i mean is it okay if i'd be
critical of you for a second please i
wouldn't i would love it yeah
so like here he is introducing you
and like he starts off with like bottles
in the back and like got arrested for
this and like
you know it's kind of a weird way it's
just a real charmer
yeah i mean how does that
i mean like because it's almost like
he's sharing like the most negative or
provocative things about you
well david's a propagandist what can i
tell you i mean he's good at it yeah
yeah so how does that how does that make
you kind of feel to be i was laughing
the entire time
i noticed that yeah that's what i was
kind of asking right because
and so i don't get offended easy doc if
that's what you're getting at i i really
don't people can say what they want i
really don't care
yeah so okay
person
so now see what david wants to make hey
out of in this situation is
basically that i'm crazy for going after
the car well i have two choices doc how
many men are gonna sit there
when four men come onto their lawn
take their property i don't give a [ __ ]
what it was took for my trump signs then
they have to
to marry me to drive around the
neighborhood three times yelling racial
epitaphs of me pointing me with the
signs out the window and i'm just
supposed to sit there like a little soy
boy i don't think so that's not gonna
happen that's not the type of person i
am i am going to do something about it
right or wrong i'm going to jail i don't
give a [ __ ] you do something like that
to me
you are you you're going to get held
responsible in some kind of way and you
know i think the whole thing's funny the
whole thing's funny you know
jimmy you kind of said that's not the
kind of person i am can you help me
understand what kind of person you are
well apparently david would have sat on
the wall and watched these morons ride
around and taunt him
david thought it was crazy for me to go
after them
yeah so jimmy i'm gonna just i may do
something a little bit unusual i may
sort of ask a question again so like
when i ask you like you said that's not
the kind of person i am and you say well
david would have done this like
i'm not interested in whatever david has
destroyed
like in other words i had two choices
right
i was either to call the police or do
nothing
but but david was trying to make me
sound crazy that and i actually took
action and went after these people that
just stole from me
and do you find i'm not the kind of
person that's going to sit there and
watch something like that
[ __ ] yeah sure i'm gonna i get it i yeah
you know i i i get that uh so i'm i'm do
you often times so what i'm hearing is
that like you know a lot of people in
your situation kind of may lay down and
take it but you're not going to lay down
and take it
why yeah but this was basically a thing
david put out there you know like i was
nuts for taking action
i was not crazy god is the type of
person i am and i wouldn't blame the guy
for not doing nothing
sure so
yeah
yeah and and do you find that oftentimes
um you know people try to like paint you
as crazy by sort of sharing stories like
this or or things like that
well i am a little nut stock i have no
problem with that
what did i do things that most people
wouldn't do
i'm very aware of that
that is my personality that's how i am
can you help me understand that a little
bit like what what do you do that other
people wouldn't like help me understand
like who are you bro
uh gee i don't know uh
i i like to have fun
okay
i see everything is funny
um okay i make fun of everybody and
everyone including myself
but see david see if i make fun of like
a homosexual or transsexual let's face
it the man in the dress is the funniest
thing since the dawn of time all right i
i'm sorry
i make fun of these folks but that
doesn't mean that i hate them if these
people want to be accepted as normal
then they better be ready to take jokes
you understand
yeah
if you're making them some sacred cow
which is what david does
and then that that's that's just they're
not special people okay
i have nothing against them but i think
when [ __ ] is funny it's funny and i'm
gonna point it out
sure so what i'm kind of hearing is that
the way that you you kind of you know
treat them in a sense fairly right
because
everyone gets made fun i don't treat
them anywhere i make fun of them
sure
yeah big deal
they can't handle that they're wearing
the dress trying to look if you look
like steve i'm not i think in new york a
landlord or an employer is fined well
over a hundred thousand dollars if they
don't refer to these people as a certain
pronoun it could be they zur zay what
that's insanity
i'm not gonna accept your delusion
go ahead and be deluded you have the
freedom to do it but you're not gonna
force me to address you
as a woman when you're clearly a man
it's it's that simple this is comp this
is logic it's science biology
yeah and and so i'm a little bit curious
jimmy when when you sort of you know
when there's a group of people that are
defying science and logic and biology
like
how does that because you seem to get
kind of passionate there as you were
talking about it how does that kind of
affect you
it pisses me off
and what pisses you off about it
what pisses me off you're trying to get
me to accept your delusion
you have the right to be delusional but
you ain't making me look if you look
like steve i'm not calling you susie
that that sums it up the whole
philosophy on the issue
sure i got no problem with gay people i
got no problem with trans people i know
i think it's funny as hell i i i think
it's absolutely hilarious
and i mocked them but that doesn't mean
i hate them that doesn't mean
if if i if look if i were the grand
poobah would i stop it no i think it's
hilarious it's a [ __ ] show i mean you
know
i just think it's funny sure
and can you understand
this may sound like a weird question
okay
but can you help me understand what you
think is funny about it
a man in a dress
that says it all
okay
my name's linda and i got a deep voice i
mean come on man this [ __ ] is funny
okay okay
i hear what you're saying
so i think part of the problem with you
know dissecting humor is this the moment
you dissect it it kind of falls apart
right
um
part of it is the commies are destroying
comedy that's what it really is
okay
everybody wants to get you don't have
the right not to be offended
you don't people can make fun of you it
doesn't make them hateful people okay
i'm not a hateful person
not a racist either
how do you know whether someone is is
you know when someone mocks you
how do you know whether that person is
hateful or not hateful
you don't but this is the way the left
paints
comedy anymore
you can't make fun of the homos you
can't make fun of the [ __ ] you know
i mean i mean look at youtube they've
got a a library of things you can't talk
about
what
why not
okay
i hear what you're saying so what i'm
also hearing that you know that they're
they're kind of
anti-science in a sense
um and that that they're also you can't
become a woman
this is impossible
i don't care if they cut their dick off
don't cut i don't care
they cannot become a woman when they can
change dna maybe you got an argument but
these people cannot become women
it's just impossible
so jimmy let me
let me kind of ask you so you were kind
of saying when someone mocks someone
else
you know you can't tell whether there's
hatred or not hatred
right
like if i mock you if i make fun of you
you know
but look if you're if you're known as a
person to do that
if you're known as a per like i used to
do stand-up comedy people that know me
know
you know i mean it's not my fault that
you're a snowflake and you can't handle
a joke
yeah i mean that's not
if you want to get offended then go
ahead and get offended i'm going to
laugh even harder
okay
so so now what i'm kind of hearing you
say is that if they know you're a
comedian then it's okay to make
you know it's always okay to make fun of
people why not humor is a spiritual
principle it actually brings people
together but the left is trying to
destroy it
okay
um
so jimmy is it okay if i ask you a
little bit about it seems like you have
a lot of really strong beliefs about
what's going on is that fair to say yeah
so is it i'm so curious can you help me
understand like how you came to these
opinions and how you came to believe
these things because i believe my ears
and my eyes when i see a man in the
dress i almost fall the [ __ ] down i'm
skipping down the street when i see this
[ __ ] like oh my god did you just see
what
i have a certain amount of sympathy for
these people but the solution isn't to
follow their delusion
it's not
dress up play barbie i don't give a [ __ ]
when you're trying it's coming down the
pike where they're gonna i'm gonna be
forced to address these people
by whatever they [ __ ] want like what
i'm i'm gonna point something out to you
so there have been like three or four
questions and i'm curious you know what
you think about that that i've asked you
about you
and your answer seems to be
doesn't involve you
so i'll ask you like how did you come to
believe these things and you kind of
started out with like saying you know
i told you i believe my eyes and my ears
and this is how my brain works
everything's funny
okay thanks for me
like i think
sometimes i don't know why
so jimmy can you help me understand a
little bit about where you grow grew up
can i ask you some questions about your
past yeah yeah i grew up in philly
okay what was growing up like for you
what was what
what was growing up
very happy
i used to be so happy i used to skip
down the streets
and of course the kids in philly broke
my balls until i stopped doing it yeah
yeah the kids on the corner i would skip
i was literally that happy and i have a
lot of energy too so kids would make fun
of me but you know i mean
that's philly for you you know you can't
do a goddamn thing without getting your
balls busted on the corner you know it's
like that's what happens in philly i
don't know
dr k i don't want to interrupt at such a
key moment but i do want to just say
because
i i'm not sure how familiar your
audience maybe is either with me or with
jimmy but this is not staged and i think
it's important that we just mention none
of this is staged first for your i'm
being serious here this is not an act of
any kind we're just having a real
conversation here yeah
i i didn't think he was saved no no no i
know you don't think i know i know you
know it wasn't staged but just for
people some people in your audience
think this has to be staged this is not
staged this is not staged okay sure so
so jimmy let me ask you apparently i'm
smacking the snowflakes
yeah
um
so jimmy so it sounds like when you were
growing up you used to like skip
and and you said people would bust your
balls for that what is that can you help
me understand what that means
well i mean i was so happy that i
literally skipped down the street as a
child
and the kids would make fun of me
it wasn't that big of a deal
i just stopped skipping down the street
i was still happier than the
[ __ ] but you know i stopped
skipping down the street
that's all
yeah and i'm i have kind of a weird
question like so do you think that i
mean how did you feel before you know
when you were skipping down the street
and people would start making fun of you
do you remember how you felt as a kid i
i didn't like it but that's that's
what happens when you grow up in
philadelphia everybody knows what you're
doing they see you you hang on the
corner
you know you got the girls you got the
guys you you know
sure so
i'm hearing that people would make fun
of you and and that you sort of didn't
like it but that's life
pretty much
yeah and i'm kind of curious like
you know this is gonna sound kind of
weird but
do you think as a kid you would have
preferred it if they didn't make fun of
you
no because it taught me how to uh come
back with snappy witty responses to uh
insults and [ __ ] i see
so you got to be on the guardian philly
you know you're hanging on the corner
you know
you got to be able to hold your own you
know sure so i'm hearing that it was
kind of like you kind of grew up right
so the school of hard knocks like it's
sort of streets
i wasn't in some really bad neighborhood
i grew up in roxbury it's almost like
the suburbs
but i hung all over philadelphia i hung
in some tough neighborhoods i was in a
boy's home when i was a child
and uh
i would hang out with the kids in their
neighborhoods kids that didn't say out
west philly
oh i've been all over philadelphia they
used to call me the rabbit
what does that mean you were in a boy's
home yeah my mom put me in a it's called
saint francis vocational school
and that
you didn't have to be adjudicated but
i was doing a lot of stupid [ __ ] i had
gotten into drugs
i committed some crimes my mother didn't
know what to do with me she put me in
this boy's home she thought she was
helping me
believe me i had a [ __ ] ball there i
didn't want to leave
but you know you were allowed out in the
community you weren't you know i had
friends i had
you know we went went to concerts like
50 of us like i went to school in the
area i mean i pretty much ah doc i have
fun
i literally have fun
everywhere i go like i have fun in jail
so
you know what i mean like i always my
number one goal is to have fun
yeah okay so can i ask you uh uh
jimmy so how old were you when you got
put into the vocational school 13.
and do you remember how you felt when
your mom kind of put you in well i i i
felt abandoned was very angry with my
mother
um i remember her crying kissing
me and my dad going
something like fly right or some [ __ ]
you know and
and but uh that wore off very quickly
but
like the con artist i was at that age
i kept
kind of letting my mother think
kind of let her letting her feel guilty
but within days like i was having a very
good time there these were all kids my
age like they put you on different
divisions
and uh there were some really cool
characters you know what i mean like i
liked a lot of these guys they had a
pool table they had a ping pong table
you know i mean i had fun there i you
know i did
i got sent to another place called st
gabe's that was a [ __ ]
that's the question when others ran that
you had to stay in line for a punishment
stand in line means you stand and face
the wall
for hours
and of course i was always online
so what what why did you get sent to
saint gabes
um the court sent me there i
um
and with the insistence of my mother
my mother thought that these places
would help me
she didn't know what to do with me what
was wrong what what did you need help
for well i was doing drugs i was
committing crimes
she thought i was going to die early
so she told me
she used to come to court and the judges
were going to let me go and see i want
him placed in and they would listen to
her and i would get real pissed off for
her now this was as a child
as an older man now i understand what my
mother was doing
you understand i agree with her you know
she just she just placed faith in
agencies that
i don't know probably made me worse
but you know as a child i [ __ ] hated
her
so i'm i'm kind of
what you're saying on the one hand makes
a lot of sense so can i just kind of
repeat back what i've heard so far
so you kind of grew up in philly right
like not like super bad situations sort
of suburbs but you kind of hung out with
some kids went to some parts of town
where you got kind of got made fun of it
sounds like you were sort of like a
happy-go-lucky kid
and yeah i've been described as exactly
that yeah and and you know the kids on
the street like they
you know they kind of got you to stop
being so carefree pretty quickly
no i just stopped skipping
sure and started being a comedian i just
started being a comedian yeah they were
calling me gay and this and that you
know i mean it's just
it just teaches you to toughen up that's
all i mean you know you're living in
philly you're on the corner you can't be
a [ __ ]
sure you can't be skipping down the
street let's put it that way then
somehow you kind of started getting into
trouble with like drugs and and some
criminal activity and stuff yeah and
then your mom kind of shipped you off to
one place
and then she kind of shipped you off
like and it sounded like you kind of did
what you were supposed to do right so
let's see here's the first thing they
did they took me to the valley forge
military academy right they were gonna
put me in there right and there was no
[ __ ] way
i was gonna be a tin soldier right so
this the the guy that runs the joint has
he said i want to talk to him privately
and he pulls me in the room and he says
listen if you don't want to come here
we're not going to make you come here
he's like i don't care what your parents
say he said do you want to come here i
said absolutely not he said okay he had
a little consultation with my mom and
dad
we walked away
how did you feel about that
great
what what yeah i mean so
i'm gonna ask you kind of a weird
question do you have a sense of why you
felt great there
because i didn't want to be a little
cadet
you know what i mean
huh
i didn't want to do that
follow orders march around wake up at
five o'clock [ __ ] that i was 13 what the
[ __ ]
i see and then how did it feel when when
you know the judge was ready to let you
come home and your mom was like oh we
got to send them to st
when i was a child that really pissed me
the [ __ ] off
what gets you off about i'm watching i'm
watching
because she wouldn't take me back
in other words i got angry with her and
i would be in the cell with these kids
from kensington where
kenston's like a real bad sex in
philadelphia
it's you know it's where the men are men
and so are the women i mean it's it's
crazy it's gotten even crazier but these
kids would do all kinds of [ __ ] like way
worse [ __ ] than me and their mothers and
fathers would pick them up
mine wouldn't you know and it it
i mean as
as young as that that that was my
thinking i couldn't stand her i [ __ ]
hated her
and my father behind her back would say
you know if it was up to me this
wouldn't happen you know so he pissed me
off too because i thought he was a
[ __ ] snowflake
you know when i got older i realized my
mother was trying to help me that's all
i was an [ __ ] i was a kid i mean i
was immature
can i think for a second jimmy
what's that
can i think for a second
you don't need my permission to think
[Laughter]
so you know jimmy what i'm kind of
hearing is that you have every reason to
be a snowflake but you'll be damned if
you're a snowflake
so
you get more respect if you're not a
snowflake see but yeah the way the left
paints people now
soyboy is the way to go a real man oh
yeah
that yeah so i i think that's exactly
what i'm saying so i'm what i'm saying
is that like you know the story that
you're sharing
makes you if you look at like if the
check boxes of being a snowflake like
getting abandoned by your mom
getting sent to a military academy
getting sent to a vocational school
getting sent to a nut like you're be you
know doing what you're graduating from
there or whatever and then you know your
mom
is like
like you're the judge is about to send
you home your mom's like i can't handle
it getting sent back to another place
huh i hated her for that yeah and so
like if you think about like you know
when you use the word snowflake what i
sort of think of is like a victim
complex right is that fair
and so what i'm thinking it like when i
hear this story bro like it sounds like
you know if any wasn't one is entitled
to call themselves a victim
it's you but you're not gonna do that
well what
now i don't
i'm not a victim of of of anything i'm
i'm i'm just
a person that's shaped by their
experiences i you know i don't see
myself as any kind of victim no i i get
i get that you don't see yourself as a
fake that's sort of what i'm saying but
if you like if you think about it right
so if you had like you know let's say a
liberal snowflake who had your
background do you think they would think
of themselves as a victim
i i i don't know
interesting okay i couldn't i you know i
can only speak for myself i mean you
know i don't know
i was a liberal till my brother put me
hip to what the corporate media does it
all started with trayvon martin like
what a bunch of [ __ ] that was and then
michael brown what a bunch of [ __ ] that
was and you got to hear about racism
like like like nothing has went forward
between the races like like it it's
systemic racism which means everything's
racist right sick and tired of hearing
this [ __ ] and my brother proved to me i
mean nbc doctored
the 9-1-1 call that zimmerman made
that's clear they admitted it they fired
two underlings but guess what this is
how the news works and david knows this
once you get someone to make an
emotional judgment a nuclear bomb of
truth isn't going to make that person
change their opinion
very few people will well because they
don't want to admit they were duped
and this is how the news works and this
is how they brainwash people
you know it's just it's sickening
uh
that's kind of interesting
so let me just make sure i heard you
correctly so once someone makes an
emotional judgment
no amount of truth is going to change
their mind
for the most part
the media that's what the media does
sure look at some hyperbolic [ __ ]
report an absolute lie
and then the truth comes out a few days
later and people already made a judgment
on it for the most part human beings are
not going to go back on the initial
emotion emotional judgment that they
made that's just
you being human yeah so yeah i think
people thinking
yeah do you think people who make
emotional judgments are aware that they
make emotional judgments
sure why wouldn't they
emotionally
you know they they know that
interesting so so you because i would
actually say like the opposite like i
would say that you know once what what
emotions tend to do is cloud your
judgment and most people who make
emotional decisions believe they're
behaving rationally and that the more
emotional you become
the more rational you think you are what
do you think about that
maybe not in all circumstances i mean
i don't know how to you know like
i said i don't know
okay it's just the way i am it's
i don't like being lied to i don't like
being gaslighted and they're doing it
constantly the media politicians you're
being lied to all the time everything's
a grift
everything is a grift
everything
when did you
when did you start to feel that way that
everything was a gift
in the last 10 years
can you tell me about
i was a bill collector for years
you know what the banks do to people and
credit cards
can you hold on just one second yeah
hello
can you get jimmy to turn off the
discord notification sound or is it you
uh it may be me i'm not sure hold on one
second
yeah i i don't
uh
so i think that we're having a problem
with discord notifications
but it shouldn't be me i don't know if
it's me or i think it might i think it
might be jimmy
yeah so jimmy we're gonna we're gonna
walk you through something okay
all right so i want you to um are you
full screen right now or can you see i'm
gonna screenshot everything
okay so in the bottom right i mean sorry
bottom left of your name
yeah hello
yeah
yeah i uh okay i'll okay
sorry all right
okay just i'm gonna put you on speaker
okay
so jimmy this is what i want you to do
um
in the bottom left of your uh
uh
screen you should see like your name
jimmy from philly and then you'll see a
microphone icon yeah a headphone icon
and a user settings
click the user settings gear
okay
and then what i want you to do is you
should see notifications about halfway
down
wait man where is it
yes
okay and then you should see a bunch of
green tabs like can you just
move those all
like turn them off so enable desktop
notifications all that kind of stuff
down stand them all off yeah turn all
those green buttons off
there you go
yeah
jesus christ
did they make it any more complicated
how the hell do i get back to you
okay so so then what you need to do you
should be uh let me hold on let me just
make sure i can navigate you through
this so then what you can do is click
that escape or there should be an x in
the top right of your screen
uh top right okay
and then you should see us again oh i
think he just dexed out the call
okay yeah oh boy then how are we gonna
there he's back here we go jimmy
jimmy bro i'm here right yep just turn
your video back on
turn the video back on
camera
there you go beautiful i'm sorry guys
like i made a youtube channel i don't
think computers at all
okay oh no just click it once it was on
um
the [ __ ] is it
uh
if you move your mouse around you should
see like four icons like sort of towards
the bottom of the call
and the the leftmost icon will be
turn off camera or turn on camera just
click that once wait a minute i don't i
don't see it goddamn it
oh man
i don't see it user settings no jimmy
not in not in user settings if you do
you see the do you see the call window
jimmy where you can see me and dr k and
then you yes yeah at the bottom of that
you should see four buttons
okay i bring the mouse there yeah turn
on the camera exactly
beautiful there we go
bro
all right
so um i so i wanted to ask you kind of
jimmy a couple things so so the second
thing is
uh you know so i'm sort of hearing like
do you think it's possible for you to be
a victim
that's
wow that's
i guess anybody can be a victim
yeah why not
and what would that mean to you if you
were a victim
uh i wouldn't know because i don't
behave like a victim
if somebody wrongs me i get back at them
you know i mean i i find a way to get
back to them and i generally make it
funny and spectacular
it's okay
that's what i do
and what what would it what would it
feel like to not get back at them
horrible in what way help me understand
that
it's just like an unpaid debt
you know
the best way i could describe it like
i got to get back at you
i mean i'm not saying be violent but
just disrespecting me
i gotta top it
yeah so what do you what do you think
about stuff like forgiveness and
compassion
uh well
you know i was in a.a for a while and
and they taught me about forgiveness
right
but then i started
um
investigating different religions and
i heard this rabbi on the tv say
he said we believe in
forgiveness too but not like the
christians and he said
we believe you've got to atone for
something before we forgive you
that i agree with the christians want
you to just forgive a [ __ ] for
just to forgive them
now
now no forgiveness should not come easy
now if you did somebody wrong
and you're looking to make amends you
got to atone for that [ __ ] before i
forgive you and i think that's more
reasonable now i'm an atheist but you
know i do some of the religions
basically it's a philosophy right
religion
some of them come up with some pretty
good [ __ ] i mean i see no problem with
treat others as you should treat
yourself
you know i mean i i think that's a good
thing you know i just don't believe
there's a god i mean it's just
ridiculous
but you know i do come up with some good
[ __ ] for human relations so you know
and
i'm gonna ask you kind of personal
question you're okay totally fine to not
answer it if you don't want to i'll
answer anything have you oh you haven't
heard my question yet
but um
have you forgiven your mom
oh yeah
yeah she
helped me understand how you did that
well i just grew up and realized that
look my mother was manic depressive she
had her own issues she was in
psychiatric hospital twice six months
right
the woman was a little [ __ ] up
you know and and
she wanted to help me there's no doubt
about it i remember my aunt from
scotland said
she my aunt i said something derogatory
about my mother and she sat me down she
said jimmy do you realize you're the
golden boy i said what do you mean
she said when there's a problem with
your eyes she wished you right off to
the doctor every time you were sick she
brought you the heart she said that
woman wasn't trying to hurt you
she had her own problems and she went
with what she thought would help you and
apparently it didn't
now yeah i i think i wish they would
have put a [ __ ] guitar in my hand or
something
i mean i was a very
happy-go-lucky energetic child but you
know they tried to make me into being
hyperactive they got me taking ritalin
they had me in a crazy kid's school you
know all this [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
you know they should have just gave me
something to keep me busy
like if computers were around then
you know i think i would have got into
that your streaming was around then
i think you would have become yourself
in the early 70s i don't think so
yeah so jimmy that's so interesting so
i'm i'm kind of hearing so what i'm
hearing is that your mom really doesn't
have anything to atone
for must look she did her best she told
me she said jimmy there's no book on how
to raise children i make mistakes
you know
so
you know my mother loved me she was a
little nuts i mean she was mag depressor
i mean you know
i mean you know
but i i know the rest of my family don't
forgive her they're they're kind of and
they're kind of um
surprised that i take the tact that i
take my sister said to me one time
she put you in a cage like my sister was
threatening to put her in a home right
my mother was definitely afraid of this
and i got real pissed off of my sister i
said look she calls me crying one more
time i'm gonna [ __ ] you up you know what
i mean like i'm tired of this [ __ ] she
wanted to die in her own home the woman
had the right to do that there was
nothing wrong with her she fell one time
big [ __ ] deal and my sister was like
literally terrifying her
and i stuck up for her my sister was
shocked she said well she put you in the
cage i'm like she put me in the cage for
a [ __ ] reason she's trying to [ __ ]
help me you ain't trying to help this
woman
i mean i don't like that [ __ ] and she
stopped
hmm you know [ __ ] that [ __ ] he ain't
gonna [ __ ] with my mom
he said it wasn't perfect she tried to
do the best she could with me
guess what you know what she told me
until you're 18 i'm gonna keep your
little ass alive
and you're gonna go where the [ __ ] i
want you to go and when you're 18 if you
die it's on you
hey it worked
i'm 58 right
right so
mom wasn't that crazy you understand
yeah so what i'm hearing from you um
jimmy is that despite you know being
very upset with your mom when you were
growing up what i'm really hearing is
that you kind of really respect her you
understand her you sort of understand
that she kind of did the best that she
could given the circumstances she had
her own struggles and you kind of don't
blame her for that sure that that's what
a mature person does it
does i mean that's that's the only way
to look at it what am i gonna still be
angry at this woman she's dead
the woman's dead
some people continue to say angry right
yeah
there's no point in it there's no no
percentage of it
so
um jimmy i'm kind of curious you said
you kind of got into drugs and kind of
criminal activity and stuff as a kid
like what's your understanding of how
that happened
well i mean
i started committing crimes to get money
for drugs okay for what and i don't want
to blame it on drugs i mean i did it i
own it but had it not been for drugs i
wouldn't have committed to crimes so
but i'm certainly committed to crimes
how do you understand
you know drug like is like so like some
people think of uh you know substance
use is an addiction is a disease is an
illness
what do you think the whole disease
thing was a bunch of [ __ ] with the
insurance companies i'm very well
reversed on all that [ __ ] on aaa the
history of it and all um
that's just the word that's all it is
it's [ __ ] whether or not it's a
disease who cares
you know like i went to aaa hey he
helped me tremendously i went through
the 12 steps in two
weeks now people said oh that's crazy
well if you study the history of aaa he
did it in days and that's a fact
but it did shake like like i had a
therapist explain to me therapy's
supposed to kind of shake you up and
then you settle down differently right
that was the best description i've ever
heard that's what it is
it got me to it got me to take a look at
things especially my mother
and i remember when i went to make
amends to my mother i went to her grave
and i cried like a baby
and i never
hooked ill of my mother ever again and i
was 38 years old so i was hating on my
mother when i was 38 years old
and i was a damn fool
but you know i did a fourth step i did a
fifth step and ran around making amends
you know what i mean got my car and just
started making amends
the men just to fix or repair something
to the best of your ability and that's
what i did
because of these actions see a lot of
these people they're just told to go to
meetings
and listen to other people's sob stories
i'm sorry it doesn't work
it doesn't work
you can't think your way out of bad
thinking you have to act your way into
better thinking and the actions that i
took to the 12 steps
it helped me even today to be more
honest to not be deceitful to not that
not that i wasn't an honest person but
you know
but
you know that
to get a real [ __ ] view of what's
really going on
rather than that dumb [ __ ] that was
running around in my head hating on my
mother hating the world thinking the
world of me a living it doesn't life
ain't fair it's not it's how you react
to it
and it really helped me i mean and then
i started to become a sponsor which was
the best thing ever because when you're
helping somebody else you ain't thinking
about yourself right
that was my whole problem i thought
about my [ __ ] self too much
i was self-centered selfish
and helping other people really i really
enjoy doing that
um jimmy i'm just going to
kind of give david a chance to kind of
uh chime in for a second
and
you know just because i noticed he's
been listening thoughtfully and maybe
taking notes dave did you want to add
anything or ask any questions or kind of
share any thoughts no i mean i think you
know one of the interesting things from
a complete layperson's perspective is
that
it's i didn't know the background of
jimmy until today
but it's exactly what i imagined it
might be
that gets him to where he is today at 58
in the sense of
i do see jimmy as a victim myself and
it's not about whether he has to quote
behave like one but
i i i you know in hearing about the
situation that he grew up in it makes a
lot of sense to me that he kind of
behaves in the boisterous way and finds
this need to always uh
have this opposite reaction to what he's
experiencing and he doesn't feel right
unless he does that that it's like an
unpaid debt i mean it's other viewers of
mine
have told me similar stories about how
they got to where they are in their 30s
40s 50s and so it just it it makes a lot
of sense everything i'm hearing is
putting a lot of pieces into into place
so the only thing
is the 70s
jimmy i'm gonna i'm i know i know you've
got you want to respond to that i said
okay if i follow up with david a little
bit and then okay so david when you said
this you know the picture that we're
kind of uncovering is exactly in a sense
what you're not surprised to hear help
me understand like what do you mean by
that why aren't you surprised to hear
this how do these dots how do the dots
of what we've learned in the past about
jimmy connect with your understanding of
him today well i mean i think it was
very interesting that i've experienced
jimmy's
um
homophobic and transphobic language
right i'll give him the benefit of the
doubt he says he he's just making fun
but he doesn't hate people that's fine
so i'll use the term i won't say
transphobia and homophobia his
transphobic and homophobic language and
for ex i've experienced it with jimmy as
an adult and he revealed today
that he was the recipient of that when
he was skipping along and being called
gay
that makes
that that
that makes a lot of sense to me in the
sense that
he's weaponizing the way he felt when
that was used against him
against other people that maybe he wants
to go after or get back at like that's
some that's one example of why it's
fitting together
um
what do you think about that jimmy
i don't know i mean david
i certainly am no victim
you know good and bad things happen to
people all the time and and in fact like
what is good and bad
what's bad don't the chinese see um
what is that um um
conflict as um
like opportunity
you know i mean if something bad happens
you can go
one or two routes right
you can
become a victim
get angry get depressed stay that way
for years or you can turn that [ __ ]
around
make lemons out
lemonade lemons right
and how do you how do you think so if
someone is kind of a victim and someone
is sad and depressed how do you think
you kind of speaking about what you were
sort of mentioning about aaa and
becoming a sponsor and helping other
people how do you help someone like that
turn
their lemons in the lemonade well
the whole thing with that is it's i
guess it's a form of selfishness i mean
if you keep thinking about you and your
[ __ ] up situation
you're not thinking about a solution
you're stuck in the problem
so you got to get out of yourself
somehow
and and for me you've been as far as
yeah so you've been a sponsor right so
you've helped people who are in the dark
space and how did you help them out of
that
just helped them with the uh
the big book of alcoholics anonymous i
helped them take them through the 12
steps
and and they got to
define it the way they did and and you
know like
they got to experience it the way they
did the more they practiced it
more they experienced and they got to
articulate it any way they wanted to i
didn't tell them to say i didn't tell
most of these guys would tell you
when i got sponsors right and believe me
these are these were all well-meaning
people but they would say call me every
day right so i called them they could
they'd last about 10 minutes because i
was
i was pissed off i was disgusted
one thing that comforted me drugs or
alcohol
wasn't available anymore and they lasted
about 10 minutes right and they would
say
go tell that at a meeting
you'll feel better i never did i never
felt better talking about my problems
all the [ __ ] time and believe me i
talked about my problems
i never understood i'm asking
how much you helped other people
what's that
so i'm hearing that you seem to be
talking about when uh someone else was
your sponsor it sounded like you were a
sponsor
yeah yeah yeah yeah how did you help
other people
oh
well what i did was i helped help them
to open their own eyes
how did they do i was helped through the
12 steps
do a fourth and fifth step with them
shared the way i made amends
discuss that with them and then they had
to go out and do the work like i was
just like
guide
i was no special person or anything i
you know i it's not like i had
superhuman powers sure
i had a problem that i got over
and you're the same way ain't you
and you have a problem with gaming and
you got over it now you help gamers well
then you understand this uh
absolutely oh sure i mean i understand
my experience of it so my experience of
it and i was kind of curious because you
know i'm sure it's similar i i think it
is too so let me let me kind of share
with you kind of my experience and you
let me know so you know i found that
when i was playing video games like
i was really struggling and and you know
some people um
would kind of you know not really
understand that i was struggling they
would sort of blame me they thought it
was weakness things like that some
people made fun of me um you know i got
bullied a lot when i was kind of growing
up for playing video games and things
like that and the people that helped me
sort of i think did sort of what you did
which is that
you know they didn't make fun of me or
or or things like that they sort of
helped me see things in the new light
they helped me sort of recognize that
that you know while i may be a victim in
some ways
that if i'm a victim if it's really my
fault like you know they also empowered
me in some ways by sort of helping me
understand that like there is some
element of this that i control
well you know hey doc you know sometimes
bullies can be good
you know they help you to face reality a
whole lot quicker
yeah so
um
if it's okay with you jimmy what i'm
gonna actually do is like share some
thoughts and and i'm kind of curious
what about this will kind of land well
with you and and what won't
um
you know and and just i'm super curious
because i think getting to talk to you
by the way first of all bro this has
been an absolute privilege i i really
appreciate it well thank you i'm having
fun
great
um
do you have a doctor by the way
you have a doctor that you see huh a
shrink
okay okay because i'm just you know
noticing that you're you're smoking
cigarettes and vaping and and stuff like
that so i just want to make sure that
you know your health is okay and that
you talk to a medical professional about
all that stuff i'm fine i'm trying to
vape more
okay
okay
um
but it sounds like you you were you
joking when you said you have a shrinker
no i said i don't have a shrink oh you
don't have any
you have like a fit physical health
doctor yeah okay and they're aware that
you're smoking and vaping and stuff like
that
okay and promote the vaping actually
okay okay um
so hard reduction now yeah
yeah it's good
so the first thing that i kind of want
to point out is is uh you know so like i
think
jimmy what i'm really hearing from you
is like
you know you grew up and you learned a
couple of really important lessons
so you were kind of like young and
carefree and and stuff like that right
and then like you kind of learned that
when
people behave in a manner that is maybe
a little bit unusual is maybe a little
bit funny
that like the way that you respond to
that like the way that you are treated
because that's how we learn right like
we treat other people the way that we
were treated right so that's how human
beings learn interactions so you know i
grew up in texas
where a firm handshake is a great way to
greet someone and so that's sort of what
i thought was normal and what i'm sort
of hearing from you is that you know
when when someone's a little bit
different
the way that you treat them is you just
kind of make fun of them right because
that's just that's just what we do like
that's the way that that's what happened
to you that's the way you kind of
respond that's sort of the system of
things
not not not always
i don't always make fun of them i
generally
what can i say
in my personal life
everyone knows me
no one takes some of the things i say
seriously but when there's a time to be
serious
they know it
you know i mean
okay
respectfully you know
can i ask you a little bit about your
personal life with event
so like who's in your life right now who
are the you know what are the
relationships that matter to you well
i live i live in a very nice rooming
house in a very nice area i run the
place
um i'm i'm the kitchen nazi
i can find you 50 if you don't clean up
now i've got to do it
but this landlord here she likes renting
all these kids and you know
[ __ ] vegetarians you know they're
gonna save the world of animals but they
won't clean up the kitchen it's amazing
you know i point to the floor so so
you're having uh artichokes onions and
looks like there's a tomato there too
yeah these kids it took me two years to
whip this place into shape now we got a
professional cleaner
yeah so
yeah
so it's it sounds like like you're
you're kind of like uh
it sounds like there are kids like in
the sense of young kids
young folks here and so it sounds like
you're you're kind of you're kind of
imposing some discipline and order
if this is the uh this is the
international house of pancakes we got
west africans we got koreans we got
jamaicans we got
black people we got
i mean we got we got everybody here
so so i'm hearing that you know the some
of the relationships in your life are
kind of the people that are in the
rooming house what about like
um you know significant others partners
family
no i don't i don't have a significant
other
my my i haven't had a steady girlfriend
since my ex and i threw the baby on the
floor
so
you know
she betrayed me and uh
you know i really
don't give a [ __ ] about a relationship
okay
when you say you don't give a [ __ ] do
you ever feel lonely
curiously enough now
that is kind of curious right how do you
understand i would no
listen i walk down the street i have fun
i talk to everybody i pet every dog i
see i i don't know what to do i have fun
i have i'm a relatively happy person
mm-hmm no i i see that i yeah but
how do you how do you think that
happened because
you know i'm thinking 58 year old
you know
well i'll say this for you lsd has
helped me tremendously
how so
just made me happier
interesting okay
and and so when was the last time you
were in a relationship
20 years ago
okay let me ask you kind of weird
question you don't have to answer if you
don't feel comfortable but have you ever
wondered if you might be gay
no
and i know it sounds kind of weird but
why not
uh
because i don't think a man's hairy ass
is appealing
that's basically as right of an answer
as you can give
okay
and so it does sound like you're
sexually attracted i got no problem i
got no problem with homosexuals i don't
in fact i've had a few homosexual
friends that were some funny
[ __ ]
yeah so i'm just hearing that you're
sexually attracted to women and you're
pretty sure about that
yeah
yeah okay
was it okay that i asked you those
questions yeah you know i hit the sucky
[ __ ] every now and then you know
what
what's that it's the sucky [ __ ] every
now and then
a massage place
and he's a massage place
okay
anyway so if you must know what i did
for sex because that would be the next
logical question and i was just
yeah i know i mean i i suppose it would
be the
next logical question
jimmy i gotta say man you are you are a
blast to talk to bro that's cool
yeah
yeah so i i just wanna you know
so here here's the thing
if it's okay with you i'm gonna sort of
share some thoughts and a couple of
observations you know i i met you now
what like about an hour ago right and
and so
you got to take all this with a healthy
grain of salt you know um
but so i'm going to kind of just start
out with like it it seems like you kind
of grew up and you were taught a
particular you know here's the rules of
the game of life
right if you're a little bit different
you get made fun of you know and that
like making fun of people is is sort of
what what happens and there's no like
there's no victim complex here you know
you kind of it's like it's like tit for
tat like if someone makes fun of you you
make fun of them and it's like that's
just the way of the world no i got to
top them
you got to top them
why is that
i don't know makes me feel better
okay
yeah
so i'll share a couple of thoughts with
you about that in a second but okay so i
and and then i think that you know
honestly like what what you're so i'm a
psychiatrist and i see a lot of people
you know who
have ptsd and gone through traumatic
experiences and stuff like that and i'm
actually i know this may sound kind of
weird but i do think that there's um you
know people some people really go too
far on the victimhood complex
and as a psychiatrist sometimes what i
find is that
you know if you play if you kind of
think of yourself as 100 of a victim
that also means that you have no control
or agency over life okay and that you
can be a victim and at the same time
there are parts of your life that you
can control
you know so i think that there were some
let me say this to you
the biggest thing that i felt
like a victim
was when my ex
used the police in the courts to lie and
say i threw the baby on the floor they
were all against me
the accusations what's meant what was
what what mattered not the fact whether
or not it happened they did no
investigation they didn't ask if the
child was taken to the hospital they
just charged me made me spend thousands
of dollars for a lawyer
to this day that pisses me off that's
the way the system is
i have detectives tell me you're guilty
till you're proven innocent
if it's with a girlfriend or a wife if
they say you did something boom you're
locked up no investigation
yeah
i believe that that's completely unfair
it's very unfair
how did it feel to be a victim in that
situation
not [ __ ] railroaded not good
i went down there and screamed at the
psychiatrist
and the security guards came in and he
put his hand up
and he talked to me
and uh
here's what he my lawyer got the notes
from the psychiatrist
said the psychiatrist said that i was
very affable right
but that i needed some
some mental health
support right yeah no [ __ ] my ex just
said i threw the [ __ ] baby on the
floor and i didn't you know what i mean
but then
he does the report on her and he says
the distance that miss beef claimed
and he threw the child on the floor
became lower and lower as the interview
went on
in other words he called her a liar
because she is a [ __ ] liar
she got away with it
she got away with it because she said
she said
that's ridiculous it pisses me off to
this day
and i don't feel like a victim anymore
but i'm still pissed off about it i'm
still gonna talk about it
you know [ __ ] ridiculous now the kids
in harvard
so and guess what that kid read books
because she saw me reading books i
always read her
prior series in their entire [ __ ]
life okay
you know
kid calls me
10. listen to this she calls me when
she's 10 years old she says daddy mommy
told me to get in the tub but i was
already in the tub i'm like what
she said mommy told me to get in the tub
but she was already in the tub
she said uh is mommy drinking she said
yeah i should put her on the phone
i said she's at the age of reason now if
you want her to hate you like i [ __ ]
hate you
keep [ __ ] drinking and to her credit
three weeks and three weeks later
she went no rehab
i believe she's still sober i'm i'm not
sure but she's been sober a number of
years
so
are you listening accomplished the kid
won't talk to me the mother poisoned her
you know the mother
got both her titties chopped off right i
found out on facebook and i sent her a
message it couldn't happen to a nicer
person i'm skipping down the street i'm
gonna have a party well apparently
saying mean things is worse than doing
mean things
you know yeah well i said it was
terrible
uh but her saying i threw the baby on
the floor costing me thousands of
dollars
forever altering the relationship i
would have my daughter is a lot worse
so you deserve that
you know what i mean i don't give a [ __ ]
they can cut their head off
i mean i don't care
yeah you sound very very angry
well what the [ __ ] what would you
threw the baby on the floor
what the [ __ ] it never happened even my
kid when she was five she's like dad
wouldn't i have gotten hurt
yeah you think these detectives would
ask those questions no but they're
forced to charge you
that's the way the law works if it's a
girlfriend or a spouse if they make some
allegation like that
you're just sent off the court no
investigation
none
so how would you like to be treated
not without evidence
how would you have liked to be treated
in that situation
like to be treated fairly
like there was some kind of
investigation to go on before i'm
charged
so [ __ ]
going to put myself in in the shoes of
someone else let's say a cop or or
you know your ex-girlfriend or whatever
and i'm going to say for a second that
you were treated fairly like what if
they thought they were treating you
fairly
even the cops admit it's unfair
i've talked to scores of detectives they
say look in that instance you're guilty
to prove an innocent
it's [ __ ] up
it's [ __ ] up no investigation like
look if somebody accused me of murder
they do a [ __ ] investigation right if
somebody accused me of burglary they do
a [ __ ] investigation if somebody
accused me of anything they do with
investigation but when a woman says a
man did something to a kid
there's no [ __ ] investigation they
just charge you
it's wrong
that shit's wrong
cost me thousands of dollars
to disprove a lie
[ __ ] yeah that's wrong
believe women [ __ ] that not without
evidence
[ __ ] that
you're supposed to get mad about [ __ ]
like that
yeah i completely agree i think the
worst thing a woman can a man can do is
rape a woman and i think the worst thing
a woman can do is lie and say that you
abused your own child
that's [ __ ] up a kid made it to
harvard
looks like i did something [ __ ] right
yeah doesn't sound like you got a whole
lot of credit for it what's that
doesn't sound like you got a whole lot
of credit for it well i shouldn't get
credit look the kid was smart
kid like to read
you know what i mean and they're all my
whole family's like thinking carol did
something that kid went to harvard
despite that dumb [ __ ]
he drank a fifth of jd a day for 10
years that kid
was born smart and she liked to read and
she would ask me daddy what's your book
he said and i would stop because my
father read all the time but he would
get pissed off he stopped him so i would
stop put the book down well julia here's
what happened so far so i'll let you
know when it ends
yeah jimmy i'm gonna i'm gonna kind of
interrupt you for a second is that okay
how does it feel to share this
good
what feels good about it
i don't know
i like talking about um
but i put it uh
about my daughter because see i can tell
the [ __ ] truth my ex has never told
the truth
and
you know apparently uh you know she's
gotten away with a lot of this
yeah not a very bright girl
but you know
so
i'm gonna try to
do this one more time
so if it's okay with you i'm gonna share
some thoughts about you know
what i'm seeing
so it kind of starts off i'm sort of
noticing that when you grew up and you
know you behaved somewhat differently
and when people didn't understand
what you were or how you were the way
you were like you know you're a kid who
skips and the kids on the corner who
like don't understand what that's about
so they make fun of you right and then
you sort of learned how to like how to
survive in that situation you also
learned that like hey you know this is
where humor comes in like you know you
kind of fight fire with fire and like
i'm sure that early on before you learn
how to
how to defend yourself using humor it
probably hurt when they make fun of you
but you sort of learned that like hey if
you get hurt laying down and playing the
victim there's no point to that you got
to kind of you you know you got to fight
back and the way that you fight back is
you put people in their place you teach
them a lesson you kind of make fun of it
you laugh with them you laugh at them
you kind of like you know that's the way
the world works
and then i'm sort of hearing that
you know that that
you had a couple of interesting things
happen to you you kind of got into drugs
and stuff like that you got into crime
because of the drugs um
you come to acknowledge that your mom
wasn't perfect in a lot of ways but she
sort of in her own flawed way did the
best that she could and you've come to
even defend her
and and kind of be a champion for her
when other people were trying to like
you know kind of abuse her or not kind
of treat her properly like you weren't
gonna let her be a victim and you would
stand up for someone else
who kind of couldn't stand up for
themselves
um and that's actually despite you know
getting sent off to
like become a tin soldier and by the way
i think part of the reason that that you
really
you know part of the reason that you
were telling that story i think
i heard some positivity there
and i think part of the positivity with
that story is that someone actually like
paid attention to what you wanted and
what you cared about and the guy was
like straight with you and said hey if
you want to be here
i got your back and if you don't want to
be totally grateful to that commander or
whatever the hell he was it's weird
right we go
yeah and he had your back right so like
you know when i was in saint gabes we
played
valley forge military academy in
football and we beat the [ __ ] out of
them
yeah
so i guess
what i'm sort of hearing is that you
know some some people like your mom it
sort of felt like she didn't have your
back right when she's in the court judge
is like time to go home and mom's like
uh-uh
whereas like it's interesting because
there are like some people here who who
sort of have your back right and so he's
like a stranger
but it's it was really interesting to
kind of hear your and see your emotional
expressions and stuff as you were kind
of telling that story you kind of got
sent to saint francis you actually you
sort of liked it but you sort of made
your mom pay for it right you weren't
going to let her off the book for
feeling that she abandoned your kid
yeah that's right
and then you went to st gabe's which you
really didn't like but it i mean it
sounds like in a lot of ways you were
sort of a dealt and unlucky hand in life
but i'm also sort of hearing that you're
not going to play the victim because
like that's not who you are
and so this is
you know [ __ ] happens to all kind of
people all kind of negative things
happen to people you know yeah of course
of course and and so i think that like
you said you know the one place where
you maybe get to play the victim card or
you feel like you were really treated um
you know unfairly was probably the
situation with this whole domestic
violence kind of thing and stuff like
that right but then i'm also kind of
hearing that that
you know this aaa experience has been
really interesting for you because what
i'm sort of hearing is that you know
acknowledging that people have their own
experience of alcohol helping people
understand their experience of alcohol
um
sorry it's just a bit distracting
and and sort of help other people sort
of like listening to you and sort of
being like kind of compassionate right
but also they're not saying like oh it's
like it's not your fault alcohol is a
disease like they're not sort of using
that kind of victim language but what
they're sort of doing is recognizing
that hey you may need a little bit of
support and i think affable and may need
some mental health support i think is a
great great way to describe you by the
way to be fair the whole disease thing
let me just stop
to be fair in the big book
and bill wilson wrote it
it did not declare the disease that he
called it an illness a melody used other
terms
the whole disease thing is a [ __ ]
joke it really it really is i think it's
i think it's ridiculous
and you know like
the problem from for me for many years
is i would go to aaa they would tell you
to go to a meeting if you got a problem
put it down in the meeting like it's
group therapy
i'm not about you but constantly talking
about my problems doesn't makes you feel
worse
it should feel worse
so
i had to like take some actions
i knew i had to do something i didn't
know what the [ __ ] to do
yeah
but this man helped me and i was very
impressed with the fact that he [ __ ]
spent his personal time with me and he
said now you go do it
yeah no i'm with you no i did i was
afraid but i did it
so i and i i'm i'm with you i mean i
think we'll i'll kind of address that in
a second too but
and so what i'm kind of hearing now is
that
you know you're you kind of got your
opinions and you're gonna stick to them
and if if people want to be snowflakes
they can go screw themselves
you're going to say what you're going to
want to say
and so this is where you know i'd
actually encourage you to rethink that a
little bit
and here's the reason why okay
so like what i'm hearing is as many
situations in your life where you were
not people didn't listen to you in other
situations where they kind of did like
so we can talk about you know that the
the the general or whatever at the tin
soldier place we can think a little bit
about your aaa sponsor we can even think
about the psychiatrists who sort of said
you know sort of had your back and sort
of looked at the situation but like you
know what doc i even look at it like
even the bowie's helped me in some sense
i'm with you i'm with you i'll get there
right so like th those those moments uh
you know where people really like you
know because i'm not hearing that your
aaa sponsor made fun of you and i'm not
hearing that when you're in a sponsor
yeah he did but he was a funny guy
he okay he just died no i was
real he died of uh hep c
he got treated
i had hep c2 i got treated and cured but
he had it for like 30 years
and he [ __ ] with his liver so bad that
even though he was
cured
he killed him which was a real shame
sounds like a real shame yeah
and and so i'm also hearing loud and
clear that you know your experiences
have made you the person that you are
which is sort of a survivor you know if
i had to use one word to describe it
you know you've been through a lot
the number one will of a human being is
to survive is it not yeah
and what i'm also hearing and i know
this may sound kind of weird but there
have been a lot of times where we sort
of talked a little bit about you know
maybe how you're feeling or or you know
like for example like that you don't
feel lonely and even you're a little bit
surprised at that and in my experience
actually like psychologically and
neuroscientifically like sometimes what
happens when people are survivors
is parts of their brain actually shut
down because like you were kind of
saying if you didn't shut those parts of
the brain down it'd be like going to an
aaa meeting talking about all the
negativity and it just sort of like
feels worse and worse and worse and so
sometimes what the brain actually does
is numb ourselves
to negative emotions
and the last kind of thing that i'd sort
of share with you is that you know you
were talking a little bit about how like
you don't like to wallow in the
negativity which i get because you're
not a victim and all that kind of good
stuff but there was a little bit of time
today where you sort of did share hey
the one place where i think if i you
know if anyone wanted to call me a
victim it was in this place you got
pissed off you started off you can even
go back and watch this you started off
laughing about it
and then towards the end you really got
angry
and then i kind of asked you like how
does it feel to talk about it you
actually said good now i'm not i i think
if we had spent an hour and a half
talking about it you would feel worse at
the end
but what i'm saying notice
maybe yeah well you're the one who said
that wallowing in the negativity makes
you feel generally speaking worse but oh
yeah
yeah so so this is where you know what i
i come kind of noticing is like you're
someone who had to kind of adapt you had
to survive you had to learn how to laugh
you had to learn how to
yeah you had to you know tit for tat
and at the same time like the cost of
that survival that survival like you
know his his comet maybe like
you know to a certain degree like
kind of toning down your compassion
toning down your empathy toning down
even feelings of loneliness or negative
emotions because you've said time and
time and time again
everything to me is funny
everything is to me is funny i'm a happy
kind of guy right
and so what i'm sort of noticing there
is like that seems really unusual and so
there's a part of me that you know based
on our conversation makes me wonder
whether there's like stuff that's kind
of like tucked away swept under the rug
that
i think i just i have a different
personality type i have a rare type i've
been typed before
i'm
just i have a rare personality type
you know does it make me special or not
and i just see things differently
i don't know yeah i i i get that i mean
i i think that you do see it's better to
lift and try
i mean i mean i had i had a therapist
tell me jimmy about my family she said
there's the brady bunch and then there's
everybody else
so you know that helped put it in
perspective you know so here's what i'd
say i i'd say that it's it's it's best
to laugh and cry
no no i ain't crying
yeah
right and like even then you kind of
said i haven't cried in a while and then
you laughed
what's funny about that
[Laughter]
yeah so because when you say better to
laugh that's kind of interesting because
well that doesn't mean i'm looking to
cry
oh i think it means you're looking to
not cry
right so when you say it's better to
laugh than to cry and every time you
laugh what i'm sort of noticing is that
you've got a choice there
and you're deviating towards laughter
instead of crying
i wouldn't say that i i think um
i'm just a happy go lucky person and and
there's there's nothing in my life that
would make me cry right now it's nothing
like you know like like like
i don't know i mean
it's not an option to cry there's
nothing to cry about things are this is
one like one the best period of my life
i got a little youtube channel
you know
i mean uh i i like that that's going
pretty good
um
yeah so quick quit one job for another
got two more hours now you know i'm
doing all right yeah i hear that man i i
i don't disagree with you i'm not saying
that you need to sit there and and you
know cry all the time oh my god your
life is crap and and things like that
what i'm sort of saying is that you know
i think that you've got maybe one or two
things that you could feel rightfully
sad about but i sort of also understand
that
you know playing a victim is not
something that you're gonna do when i
think a little bit about your daughter
and and her being at harvard and i hear
you kind of speak with pride and also
that she's been poisoned against you
like i think it'd be okay to shed a tear
on that if you felt like it
nah you know sometimes i get a little
sad about it but
i've
i basically convinced myself that look
a kid has reached
the pinnacle of schools
she's not gonna run for anything she
plays her cards right and up to now
she's played her cards right so she's
not gonna need her father that much and
if she doesn't want me in her life then
that's her choice
there's nothing i can do about it
so you used an interesting one
i've gotten a few hobbies look i started
painting
yes that's great
yeah um
jimmy i just want to point one thing out
to you and then we can you know can that
discussion but okay you said i've
convinced myself
so when someone uses that word
when i think about convincing what i
think about is starting from a place
where you believe one thing and working
really hard to believe something else
in a sense yes because look let's face
it that's a sad situation the kid ain't
talking to me right there's nothing i
can do about it
there's nothing i can do about it so
hopefully the kid grows the [ __ ] up and
you know like
apparently it was okay for this woman to
falsely accuse me three times
twice of abusing her once i'm abusing
yeah so
jimmy can i cut you off again is that
okay okay so here's here's what i'd say
i'm with you that there's nothing you
can do about it so a lot of times when
there's nothing we can do about
something like why cry about it right
because it's not gonna help anything i'm
with you
makes perfect sense right so like why
why what's use of crying over spilled
milk
right
with you there
so this is the last thing that i'd leave
with you and you know you you don't have
to agree with whatever i'm saying it's
really just i'm just making observations
and you can you can decide you know
you're the expert on you
so the last thing that i'd say is like
you know i'd encourage you to try
you know if you're a funny dude that's
fine you find something funny that's
fine
um i'd encourage you to try to be like a
little bit more compassionate towards
people who may be confused or struggling
or see themselves as victims
i'm not saying that they are victims i'm
not saying that there's an objective
right or wrong but what i've heard from
you time and time and time again is that
there have been periods in your life
where like whether you were a victim or
you weren't a victim
you know whether it was really your
fault that you got sent off to these
schools or things like that whether they
formed you into being the person that
you are and so therefore good
experiences i'm with you all all through
that even in terms of my own video game
addiction i'm grateful for it because it
turned me into the person that i am
and at the same time while i'm going
through it
if someone sort of shares a kind word
with me even if my head is in the wrong
space i don't understand exactly what's
going on you kind of said that about
yourself you know when you were kind of
like going through this a a stuff and
you started to have realizations that
during that dark period before you
understand things
that a kind word or even someone sort of
like you know taking you seriously and
saying hey i don't think that's really
what it is
can actually have like a positive impact
and what i'd encourage you to kind of
think about is like you know these
people that you kind of call snowflakes
and stuff like that
you know i don't know if there's an
objective right here or an objective
wrong you may think that there's an
objective right i think that it's
possible that your decisions are also
your judgments are also emotional and
then you know no amount of truth is
going to change your mind what i'm
saying is just like from a human
perspective even if you can think
they're ridiculous can you be kind to
them too
oh absolutely
one one of one of the quotes
in the book of alcoholics anonymous says
those we dislike
we practice justice and courtesy
so
i mean
you got to be fair with people and you
got to be silly you know you got to try
to be civil with them
you know we really should fight fire
with water you know
quite often i gotta fight fire with fire
that's what happened but yeah
yeah what do you think about that bro
i get myself into some situations
yeah
so
you know just one last thought and then
you know david can talk or you can talk
i'm kind of done with my spiel but you
know just like you said like it sounds
like a lot of times you fight fire with
fire and and the words came out of your
mouth like something maybe you should
think about using water from time to
time bro oh yeah
sometimes weather doesn't make sense
when when you're dealing with somebody
who's irrational and unreasonable
well i
i
look i'm not saying that fire isn't
appealing
but i'd i'd even argue that the more
rational someone is
the more water helps rather than fire
i don't know if they're willing to
listen
yep
yeah i think it's tricky but you know
i'm hearing that maybe you're rethinking
things a little bit but you know you
came to use fire for a reason right
because the water wasn't working well
and at the same time
maybe there's some exploration to have
there
i think with what i went through in my
life
i've turned out pretty goddamn good
and i'm relatively happy
so
yeah
yeah no problem with my life
i i think i think you've done a good
i'm about to say something that make you
let me know if this is like a victim
complex kind of thing but i would say
given the hand of cards that you've been
dealt you played a really good game of
poker
yeah maybe
believe me i [ __ ] up along the way
yeah
learn more from [ __ ] ups than any kind
of success trust me abs absolutely man i
hear you yeah you're as overrated
underrated hey jimmy can can i ask a
quick question jimmy you know when you
when you and i started kind of uh i
don't know about corresponding but when
you started calling in
there was a different sort of anger
that i feel like in our interactions has
dissipated over time where you and i
have even communicated privately by
email
and i feel like it's a different jimmy
than from maybe a couple years ago is
that about
something has changed for you over the
last couple years or is that about your
relationship with me specifically
i would say lsd has helped me
hmm
that's i honestly believe that it's made
me happier
i honestly now i get in arguments with
these people online they say oh it
taught me this it taught me that lsd
it's a drug it ain't teaching you [ __ ]
but it does seem to make me happier it
does seem to make me want to take risks
now like i i was afraid to start the
youtube channel that i got i was
unconfident about it
i don't know how to do this i don't know
how to do that [ __ ] it i just did it
i didn't even know how to do this [ __ ]
you guys helped me right so
i see somebody who doesn't know how to
do something i'm willing to help them
that's how it should work right so you
just have to have the will to do
something you don't necessarily have to
understand it
you know how to do it you just move
towards it right
so that's what i'm doing words to live
by wow and jimmy i'm just curious and
you don't if you don't want to answer
that uh this obviously you don't have to
do you own firearms
you know okay i'm a felon
okay okay
i wouldn't own one anyway i have no
problem with people to do
but i have no need for a gun oh is that
right
yeah i've you know
i could defend myself but some people
it's their right
i don't think they have a right to do it
i lost that right by being
convicted so yeah well
wow
well jimmy listen you you've really said
it all i mean i don't know about you dr
k but this has been
incredibly illuminating to me
same
yeah i mean i i i really appreciated you
know jimmy's honesty and his perspective
and
his cojones for coming on and and kind
of maybe stepping a touch outside of
that
yeah i hear you man yeah maybe that's my
oh sorry dr k no go ahead go ahead nope
i was just gonna say like jimmy you
gotta you gotta talk to your doc about
you know all the stuff you're using bro
okay
yeah that was actually that was actually
going to be my question
no but jimmy what i was curious is
during this hour and a half i think it's
been
consistent
cool whip cigarettes and vaping the in
the entire time is this all day while
you're up or are you maybe like
understandably a little nervous about
this conversation so you're doing it or
is that all day
well listen
whippet gods were good to me
they just delivered
615 minutes before the stream started
no but what i'm asking jimmy is from the
time you wake up till you go to sleep
are you consuming the whole time no no
no
you're not but i
i do hit these whippets a little hard i
mean you know but not in the morning or
not you know i mean
okay
and then absolute last thing just
because aaa was such a prevalent thing
are are you sober now from the
standpoint of alcohol
no but i don't drink as much
okay i was knocking down two bottles of
that whiskey a week
i've had that for 10 days
the bottle behind you
yeah so i'll drink uh
i'll drink um
three strong beers nine or ten percent a
night
of course of five hours
so i'm not driving i'm doing a stream
david i'm kind of curious what
what pushes you to ask
questions to
uh phil about his i sorry jimmy about
how much substances he's using well my
i'm curious in my interactions with him
how influenced by substance use they
might be because i'm hearing you know
i'm getting an email or hearing a
voicemail
and
my instinct is it would help me maybe to
frame the context a little bit if i know
maybe what a state of mind is that's my
kind of curiosity about it
well
okay
well jimmy any questions from your end
yeah
i i had a great time thanks fellas
all right
thank you very much for joining me here
let's do this again
sure
david you want to go and wrap up or yeah
well listen i appreciate everybody's
time jimmy uh you know you and i have
known each other a couple years now in
some sense and this has really been
informative for me i feel like i better
understand you now
and uh you know dr k i really appreciate
you lending your expertise and uh
um uh
you know leading us through this i feel
like i've learned a lot
yeah
well i mean let me say this david
my end game here with you right is to
get you to debate the hard bastard
and one day you're gonna do it sorry who
the hot bastard
the hard bastard okay all right well
let's we'll let's talk about that in
this new spirit of openness and uh
exploration and honesty
this sounds great
our bastard is a youtuber
that eviscerates you david every night
he streams in fact he'll be on tonight
doing a segment on you okay all right
good absolutely hilarious it's
absolutely hilarious david all right
very good
uh okay thanks so much guys dr k really
appreciate it
yeah thanks a lot for the opportunity
jimmy it was nice to meet you man thank
you guys david take care thanks for
setting this up all right my pleasure
bye all right we'll talk to everybody
soon take care
wow
uh what a day what a day um let's just
see here what else uh we've got here
really quite a conversation um
man it's uh an historic and exhausting
day but i feel like we've really learned
a lot here we've really really really
learned a lot
um
let's see what's happening over here
and beat them at their own game
sometimes fire doesn't work you gotta
use water
yeah
very uh very instructive
all right guys very
i don't know what else to say let's all
digest it we'll get this turned around
and re-uploaded to youtube and to
everything
um
and we will uh
we'll be back with everybody very soon
alright guys thanks for joining me and
maybe we'll do this again with another
viewer i don't know maybe with jimmy in
a year who knows
um
i am worried about the the whippets and
the smoking and everything i mean that
that was a lot
that was really a lot